We use maps every day to figure out how
to walk from home to school, and then
from school to soccer practice.
Scientists also use maps to navigate
through the enormous amount of DNA in a
cell-- 3 billion base pairs in humans.
The DNA is organized into several long
strands called chromosomes. Within each
chromosome are genes, regions of the
DNA that specify traits, like eye color
or blood type. But how are these traits
ordered in the DNA, which genes are
close together and which are far apart?
To answer this question, you need a map.
Back in the early 1900s, two scientists
named Alfred Sturtevant and Thomas Hunt
Morgan, made the first map of genes in
the fruit fly, Drosophila. But before
we get into Morgan and Sturtevant's
research and its implications, let's
quickly review what was known at the
time about how traits are inherited.
Fifty years earlier, Gregor Mendel, a
monk who performed experiments on pea
plants, noted that traits, like whether
the plant's flowers were white or
purple in color, or whether the peas
were round or wrinkled in shape,
assorted independently. If you breed a
white flower, round pea plant with a
purple flower, wrinkled pea plant, you
can get any combination of these traits
in the offspring plants.
Thomas Hunt Morgan studied two traits
in Drosophila: eye color, which could
be either red or white, and the length
of the wings, long or short. If you
bred a white eyed, long winged fly with
a red eyed, short winged fly, the
offspring almost always resembled one
of the parents. They were either white,
long or red, short. Unlike the
experiments from Mendel, these traits
were not assorting independently.
Instead, these traits were, what he
called, linked to each other. So what
was going on? Morgan guessed that the
genes coding for these traits must lie
on the same chromosome. So when sperm
or eggs are formed the two genes from
the same parent always went into the
same sperm or egg cell, they stayed
linked together. In contrast, if they
were on different chromosomes, then the
genes and their traits should sort
independently, as described by Mendel.
Interestingly, however, Morgan also saw
that occasionally some of the offspring
from the white-long to red-short
breeding had a different appearance
from the parents. He would sometimes
get white-short or red-long offspring
flies. How could this have occurred if
the genes are linked? Morgan's
hypothesis, which we now know is
correct, was that maternal and paternal
chromosome pairs can exchange pieces of
DNA with each other. This exchange is
called crossing over or recombination.
If the crossover point occurs in
between the gene for eye color and the
gene for wing length, new combinations
of traits, like white-short or
red-long, could be found in the
offspring. So what does this have to do
with maps? Morgan's student, named
Alfred Sturtevant, reasoned that the
frequency of crossover could be used to
infer the approximate distance between
genes on a chromosome. And if we know
distance between genes, we can make a
map.
How did he do this? Let's look at the
chromosome pair below. If the genes for
eye color and wing length are very far
apart from each other on the chromosome,
it is very likely that recombination
could occur at a spot in between the
two genes. This means it would be
likely to get new combinations of
offspring that were distinct from their
parents. In contrast, if the eye color
and wing length genes were very close
to each other on the chromosome, it is
much less likely that the chromosomes
would cross over in between the two
genes. So in this case, we would not
expect to get many offspring that had a
different appearance from the parents.
Then Sturtevant analyzed six different
genes that he knew were all found on
the same chromosome. He determined the
percentage of crossover events that
occurred by looking at specific
features in the offspring when he bred
different types of flies.
The higher the percentage of crossing
over, the farther apart the two genes
were on the chromosome, and the
lower the percentage of crossing over,
the closer the two genes were. By this
method Sturtevant deciphered the order
of the six genes on the chromosome and
approximately how far apart each one
was from the other. This amazing
finding established that chromosomes
are linear and that the genes are
organized within each chromosome in
defined positions.
The Sturtevant-Morgan findings have had
long term implications. Scientists have
used similar genetic mapping strategies
to pinpoint the location of, and then
clone, a gene of interest. On a grand
scale, scientists constructed genetic
maps of thousands of genes in
Drosophila and humans, and then took
this concept one step further to
sequence the entire 3 billion base pair
human genome.
The genome sequence is the ultimate
high resolution map. Even now,
scientists use genetic mapping to find
a connection between a genetic disease
that runs in families and gene
mutations that might underlie the
disease.